and guys we the channel has been kicked
off the YouTube Partner program I
shouldn't be admitting this but
saving children right
that was great it was saving you guys
better
[Applause]
yeah man this is tough bro
oh
my God
[Laughter]
at the moment we are currently on tour
so that's why we're in the setup it
looks a little bit different we're
sitting we weren't going to do any
videos while we was out here but
what happened sometimes happen because
this [__] told me that this [__]
happened and then I was like okay while
we were out here taking dubs on tour you
know doing some of our first live shows
let me just say meeting you guys in
person has been amazing great
um some big news just dropped
YouTube made some decisions
no
let's go ready here we go
and we are live what's up guys welcome
to the fresh trip podcast man we got a
very important announcement for you guys
let's get into the show let's go
[Music]
how much times you guys hear this intro
I was just kidding I'm just kidding you
guys can hear this intro as often as you
want if you go to rumble
all right and we are live what's up guys
welcome to the fresh and fit podcast man
um as you guys know we had a show
scheduled earlier with psych hacks but
we had to uh cancel because we got some
really you know sucky news
um crazy news yeah crazy news real talk
yeah uh right now we're live streaming
on Facebook YouTube Twitter or twitch
Rumble
um and guys I mean
is this the ambro because uh we got some
bad news man uh I mean when I heard I
was I was shocked because I mean
we love you too man yeah we love
streaming yeah and um at this point I
feel like our whole lives are all the
wrong streaming and like yeah you know
people online it's just like
it won't be the same bro yeah
in 2020 guys uh as you guys know
um yeah
I was working for the government right I
was a special agent Homeland Security he
worked for [__] it Wix we'll just call
it yeah right um yeah all right so these
are like little SOB moments where they
relive the tales of the good days you
know
so I'm just gonna put 1.5 because I
don't give a [__] and uh you know he was
a tech support I was arrested bad guys
Etc
we started this podcast we did our first
episode on October 26 2020. it was a lot
of fun yeah and um yeah Chris was there
the apartment was all empty and [__] you
guys remember the days before we started
just making a podcast where we [__] on
women every day remember the days we
used to work at Wix and you were a loser
and then I used to put out like illegal
immigrants Behind Bars
and then we got together and we're just
like yo these [__] [__] and we'd
made Millions
man
the good old days
dumb horse
you're awake November like 14th
Internal Affairs hey we need you to come
in for an interview and I'm like oh my
God here we go right and I'm working at
the Garden I'm sitting at my desk
writing up a report and I see this email
this is 2020 November and I uh you know
I go uh you know I let my supervisor
know hey I gotta go up to you know the
Internal Affairs office right because
it's not the same building as us and you
know I go over there and they and they
take my phone and I'm like what the hell
like what's going on here and then you
know and then they're like they didn't
want to tell me but they're like uh you
know hey you know we're part of an
internal investigation next I meet up
with the you know the special agent in
charge
and they tell me hey it has to do with
your YouTube and right there I clicked I
was like wait hold on
[Music]
yeah you probably can't work for the FBI
and also be like yo these [__] [__]
man
I'm sorry
yeah yeah probably not yeah the FBI is
probably gonna frown on that yeah
the FBI is probably gonna have a problem
with that Homeland Security is probably
not one or some dude just be like hey yo
these [__] deserve less
[Music]
I like that this even needed a
conversation like even working as a
government clerk you probably can't have
a YouTube channel doing this no but
anyways probably thinking I'm recording
videos on my phone like that's what it
is which it was a [__] like iPhone
six or seven of those piece of [__] uh
and um
and uh when they're happening is I had
to make a really tough decision that
month I remember going back and forth
trying to negotiate trying to figure out
what we're going to do and uh you know
they're like no like you have to pick
one you have to either
you're gonna be a YouTuber or you can be
a special Homeland but you're not gonna
do both
and I had to make that decision I
remember you were there yeah we had
Andrew here and I was like well we got
people working for us now there's people
that depend on us you would pretty much
quit your gig so I was like all right
I'm gonna resign and I walked in
December 5th turned in all my stuff
and uh yeah I walked away from the from
the US government it was a good
you know a six-figure a job uh it was
stable it was a lot of fun I enjoyed it
you guys know on my fed reacts you guys
see how I talk when I'm when I'm talking
on that channel and uh yeah and and I
haven't I say I tell you guys that story
to tell you that I haven't felt like
that
since today
and
um it sucks guys it really does suck
um you know fortunately we know we made
some moves Etc you know and we kind of
saw knew that the type of content that
we make for us to be able to give you
this content we have to it comes at a
cost it comes at a cost and it will be
forever yeah I said this you know enjoy
us while you can yeah uh it's always
happening man yeah if that was a joke
and you know we did we made moves on the
side knowing that this could potentially
happen and guys we the channel has been
kicked off the YouTube Partner program
just keep it straight if you look right
now you can't do a super chat right now
okay they're just off the partner
program
that's 95 of their revenue yes
so it's not just
they make their money listen for all the
[__] I talk they are top three in terms
of how much money people donate the
amount of dudes who want to be like yeah
you know they have the panel with the
women and the dudes donate a hundred
dollars to be like tell that dumb [__]
with the blonde wig that her Daddy
doesn't love her like there's dudes who
paint that every day so you know felt
like they were top of the line that's
how they made their money yeah they're
the only fans of YouTube
yeah so you literally can't Yeah man so
it's uh so basically
we're we're gonna figure out what's
going on because we don't even really
know all the details
um we're working with YouTube to try to
come to the middle ground and you know
work together and figure this out but
for now we don't even know why we yeah
we don't know the specific reason
um but we don't in any form fashion
Chris hey YouTuber wanna go out them
we're just saying you know what we wish
we knew the reason why but we respect
you know use the platform and keeping us
here for a while and like yeah you know
we appreciate it yeah but and the thing
is is that you guys know right on this
uh pod we push the edge right we put it
we push the envelope where there's no
we're not gonna lie about that like we
give you guys the real deal when it
comes to getting in shape when it comes
to 20 girls money dating improving
yourself Etc and unfortunately
to be able to give people
real advice that they can take in real
life and apply to the real world you
have to have uncomfortable conversations
about uncomfortable topics
in uncomfortable times
I said it when they did the whole monkey
thing yeah
I didn't realize that when fresh outfit
put out that live stream and said they
were gonna nuke our Channel they just
ended up nuking their own so you know if
you're proud of this congratulations
brother you played yourself I don't
think there's much to be said I wouldn't
be surprised if the YouTube channel gets
deleted fresh my man's 28 going on 80
and I don't want that to be you guys and
that's why today's sponsor t.h Hanley is
coming in to save the day I get
compliments on my skin all the time
people be asking what's your skin care
routine how do you get your skin and for
a lot of fellas talking about skin care
is a little bit awkward because either
we're too ashamed to do it or it seems a
little bit too feminine but the truth is
having rough skin or having all these
little dents everywhere isn't some that
you necessarily want especially if it's
things that you can easily avoid through
very very good products I recommend
going through that process and that's
where teach Hanley comes in they got a
great system in place where you can use
their products to achieve your skin care
goals I personally recommend that you
start with the level one system which
comes with all the basics a daily face
watch which gets rid of all the dirt and
Grime on your fix then got it two times
per week exfoliating scrub to get rid of
all the dead skin cells and an AM
moisturizer with SPF 20 because we all
need to make sure that our skin is
protected from the Sun and the cool
thing about tier Shanley is all their
boxes come with instructions in addition
to amazing skin members of th Henley get
tons of benefits like at least 20 off
retail price the ability to pause or
cancel at any time as well as free us
shipping and because thinly is
sponsoring today's video if you go to
the link in the description below not
only will you get all the benefits that
I just listed but you'll also get a free
gift with your purchase
don't wait rub out that face so you can
actually start looking fresh
I set it to sneaker when he did the
whole [__] him simulating graping a
girl yeah another YouTuber
it was it was about and this is why I
didn't even want to go back and forth
with Ethan Klein it's like when you
bring up certain drama it brings bad
press people start writing articles okay
and YouTube just doesn't like that they
don't want bad press so even though
these guys were bringing in so much
money to YouTube and their income they
weren't worth the negative cost that
they potentially would bring with a bad
press story and that's what these guys
are they're they're they're a bad news
story waiting to happen the New York
Times will probably write something
someday about misogyny being rampant on
YouTube or racism or whatever it is
being rampant on YouTube and they're
gonna play clips of these guys doing
Monkey noises and calling people all
kinds of things right or doing the KK
you know putting on the white Hood right
they're gonna play those clips
YouTube doesn't need that kind of bad
advertisement you want to be able to be
free to do whatever you want YouTube
says sure but we're not going to make
you part of the partner program We're
not gonna allow you to make money off
this site because we don't want to be
associated with your brand
so they're sitting here now like they
don't get it but like all these
conspiracy theories that they've been
bringing on their platform all the dumb
[__] that they've done you know they
want to sit here and cry about it now
but I already said you were willing to
throw away your platform to do the
dumbest unfunniest jokes possible the
dumbest Minstrel show so it's easy to
sit here and be like oh this is so
devastating but you weren't really
thinking about your platform or
maintaining your [__] when you were
doing that dumb stuff
you know it's easy to say oh I care
about my girl I can't believe she left
me you were cheating on her for five
years
you cheated on her with her sister you
were doing flagrant dumb [__] and then
you want to cry afterwards about how
much you cared it's kind of hard for me
to take it seriously I don't want nobody
to lose their stuff but it wasn't
surprising to me the same way it's not
surprising when the other guys you
called it I told preacher private I said
they're probably gonna lose their [__]
over this and it was and I was the one
to say I was the one to say I was not
believing in that because I to be honest
with you sometimes when stuff like that
happens I really don't believe in the
system I don't believe in things that
are in place and sometimes I'm like
the experience that I had in life was
like I don't believe in I don't believe
in what they say when I mean they I'm
talking about uh the system in place in
their rules
right I feel like like sometimes it's
not fair and I was like maybe not
probably not
and then it just takes time I guess it
just takes a whole lot of time for them
to sit down and be like you know what
let's just review this
[Music]
funny the the same way that it took time
to take like they need to
rally everything up and
watch and uh and and put it like a a
file together to just justify this
that's the same thing that happened
there
this stuff could even happen to me and
preached someday I could you know that's
why you don't celebrate this kind of
stuff no because you know we have takes
that are probably not the most popular
when it comes to trans women sports or
whatever it is and you know I've always
accepted that I'm probably gonna lose
this platform someday so when that
happens I'll be okay with it I'll be at
peace it'll suck but like it is what it
is
um you know I'm not married to this
thing I understand it but I also try to
take steps to be smart about what
battles I choose not every battle is
worth fighting when a dude's putting on
a monkey suit or putting on a hand a
clan Hood like I'm not I'm not trying to
be on that level of dumbness right and
you're going to be able to say that oh
well you know what that when they did
that they would not they were not on
they were not on YouTube so linked like
I said they don't like the Press they
say YouTuber is out here wearing the
hood maybe it doesn't matter whether it
was on or off the platform it looks bad
for the the platform that it looks bad
for their business and that's what it is
YouTube is a business at the end of the
day guys it's about to be an election
year
you know what I mean we're talking about
certain points and we've brought up
certain points that might not be
politically correct right that might not
necessarily align with everyone's
viewpoints right and we've worked really
hard to bring people on that have
different viewpoints right some of them
very controversial some of them that may
or may not be
um
politically correct and
that's unfortunately the risk that you
take when you make the kind of content
that we do even other platforms like a
rumble they're taking a huge beating on
the stock market yeah I mean despite
having one of the best years for uh
revenue and for views and everything and
uh so this comes at a cost no matter who
you are company individual Creator yep
and a lot of you guys want to be
aspiring RV creators as well and I
respect that but just know at a certain
level it will cost you a price you got
to pay and uh I think me and Myron
understand this and we were saying you
know what at some point we're gonna have
to deal with this price and today yeah
yeah and and my thing is guys um more
than ever
real talk more than ever
I know a lot of you guys send me
messages and trust me I look at them I
really do look at them and as a matter
of fact I save them too because I sent
some of them to Fresh today yeah when
you guys send your DMs and say yo you
saved my life yo you send me a picture
of your credit score yo my girl is
making sandwiches now or whatever it is
right
yeah don't kill me bro
don't kill me bro
don't kill me
yeah you know what [__] it I'm I'm
mad at you being these [__] bro
we need more women making sandwiches bro
yo we need more sandwiches in life
yeah I can't believe
you imagine this [__] dweeb on a date
you know what you used to do I used to
be a federal agent what do you do now
man I help men get they women and make
[__] sandwiches [__]
oh
my God he didn't say that she said I was
getting attacked on at all angles I've
been like
whether it's the Press writing articles
on us
videos getting taken down that other
channels are not getting taken down and
it's the same exact content or whatever
it may be Rubble getting hit right for
free speech uh video like just get
strikes whatever maybe
guys it's got to the point now where
even where we shoot the location doesn't
want us to stay here yeah
right but dude there is like there is a
matrix man like this is that's what I'm
that that's what I just said oh yeah
these guys are such cornballs all these
Matrix loving losers like they never
address all the lies they tell they
never just all the the [__] infactual
evidence that they love to provide the
[__] bro signs that they believe in
they just blame the matrix it's crazy
how they say women are allergic to
accountability but these [__]
run to the Matrix when it comes to
accountability I mean I mean we've
talked about this with Andrew and length
like people don't want you guys to get
this message dude even rumbles under
attack too bro for everybody yeah
they're trying to sell Rumble down like
I think at some point there was free
speech where it was like okay you know
what you see what you got to say We'll
crucify you but nowadays free speech is
kind of like it's a different thing I
mean not really stop bringing up free
speech like it's not about Free Speech
you have the right to say that's why you
weren't paying from the platform
entirely they're just saying you're not
gonna make money from us which is
entirely acceptable like you guys are
demanding that YouTube pay you that
YouTube employ you why would imagine if
I came to your job and I said you had to
employ me
under what circumstance do I have the
responsibility to continue paying you
when you're doing stuff that's
detrimental to my business that's not
free speech you want to [__] hand out
you want them to just give you stuff
because you feel you're entitled they
want to end out like those girls that
want to be paid okay whatever I think
it's fair to say to YouTube if you guys
are going to terminate this you should
be able to tell us why but it's not act
like you're [__] dossier is free of
issues let's not act like YouTube hasn't
spoken to you numerous times about the
dmca strikes about the other things that
y'all been doing or the strikes that you
guys have been given or the warnings
that you've received
y'all acting like y'all got fired out of
nowhere
bruv we've all seen you get called into
the office a few times stop I'm not
gonna watch any more of this uh because
I think it's pathetic watching grown men
refuse to take any accountability for
any of the situations they're in I think
them going to rumble is going to be a
big L as it has been for pretty much
every Creator who's transferred over
there
um but hopefully if they're able to make
good short form content on YouTube or on
Tick Tock and that gets them more
viewership then I think their stuff will
keep growing but
um if they don't do that then I think
over time the viewership numbers are
going to Tweet her out as they become
less relevant
but it'll probably take a couple years
anything else you want to say no
you were right
yeah
I got nothing else to say but you were
right you know you know when it comes to
this [__] you know your [__] hey bro I
just tell you man when I see people make
bad moves like as a business owner I'm
like I could see why your business I
didn't think I didn't think it would
happen I don't know I'll tell you
YouTube is serious about their business
I also say this
y'all said y'all were gonna end our
careers that's that's weird that's where
that happened
that yeah I was thinking y'all said I
mean I'll do the whole live streaming
end our careers
they also said that it would lap us but
all right listen it's good luck
guys I'll go need it godspeed and of
course comes to worse you can stop
helping dudes make their girlfriends
make sandwiches and go back to being a
Fed
and fresh you can go back to bagging
groceries and sleeping with sugar babies
anything else
I don't give a [__]
I said I was gonna take the high road
but [__] these with a little bit of a
low road there [__] these anyway when
caught with Karma happens the same way
that a woman talks [__] and be like what
you gonna do what you gonna do what you
gonna do and then and then pushes the
[__] and just push the person
and push the person and what you gonna
do and it was the extreme thing and just
push his head and get decked I'm like
Karma I'm not for it
but karma what happened should have
happened what should have happened
happened and
it is what it is yeah that being said
coconuts in Barbados
[Music]
ah
coconuts and bottom
yo I'm about to hit up AC I'm like yo
listen my enemy of my enemies my friend
me and she about to do a live stream bro
yo yo let me message them real quick
actually I'm about dmh3h